[Musique]
bonsoir décidément la frère greégory est
un vrai roman policier aucune Pedy James
aucune Agatha Christie nurait imaginé de
telles rebondissement mais à la fin de
leur livre il y a toujours un dénouement
et bien pour l'instant dans l'affaire du
petit grégoryi assassiné il y a 5 ans on
enemble loin dernier rebondissement cet
après-midi Marie an Laroche son frère et
sa sœur qui se rendaiit au Palais de
Justice ont été trouvés en possession
d'armes tous les trois en effet étaient
armés changement de parcours ils se sont
retrouvés à la brigade criminelle je
vous rappelle que Marie Ange Laroche
c'est la femme de Bernard Laroche
soupçonnée de l'assassinat de grégoryi
et assassiné à son tour par le père de
Grégory villmain Dominique
verdeillan pistolet à grenail pistolet
lacrymogène couteau à cran d'arrêt en se
présentant armé Marie-Ange la roche
Muriel bol et son frère Lucien ont fait
de ce qui ne devait être qu'une audience
de routine un nouveau rebondissement
dans le dossier greégory pour leurs
avocats ce fait était prévisible cet
incident traduit une situation
extrêmement
déplorable concernant l'état
psychologique de nos clientses qui sont
désespérés et qui vivent dans la terreur
depuis la mort de Bernard Larroche et ce
désarroi continuera tant que Jean-Marie
villmain n'aura pas comparé aux assises
et tant qu'on continuera sous prétexte
de faire la lumière sur l'affaire de
Grégorie àer traîner dans la boue c'est
une véritable chasse à cour elles ne
peuvent plus psychologiquement supporter
tous trois devaient être entendu suite
au dépôt de plusieurs plaintes contrrix
pour violation de l'instruction de
nouvelles plaintes concernant les
récents entretiens du juge Chimon à la 5
et au nouveau détective et dans lequel
il évoquait la piste la roche éléments
bon il lui manque un pas coméie pour
savoir si c'est lui l'assassin alors que
les avocats de la partie civile de les
grands-parents de Grégory disent il n'y
a rien contre la
roche le procureur général en dit de
même il n'y a rien contre Bernard
Laroche et aujourd'hui il se permet de
avoir donc de de crier que Bernard
aurait enlevé l'enfant
alors pour moi c'est plus possible je
n'ai plus confiance en
lui après 3h à la brigade criminelle
marieange Laroche et ses frères et sœurs
sont sortis libres du Palais de Justice
l'audition a été reportée au 10 novembre
les trois plignants ont été convoqués
sans
armes